[Music]
you know that old saying about the fox
guarding a henhouse
so I like to tell it for a different
version of that story the backstory you
know where the hens regular people
trying to live our lives and we had a
guard of the henhouse it's the
government wasn't perfect but it but it
did a reasonable job of protecting us
from each other guarding equality make
sure making sure none of the hens were
you know pecking the other ends too much
and then came along last 30 or 40 years
a fox on the fox's big business and
wealthy people and the Fox didn't like
you know the guard because the Fox kind
of one of the ends to itself and so what
the Fox do a bit bit that garden like it
argued that government was bad
government was the enemy it defunded
government and fought for lower taxes so
government could do less stuff then the
guard starts stumbling away and bleeding
out off the scene hens are unguarded and
the Fox presents itself to the hens and
says what a shame
government is just not not what it used
to be not not solving not protecting you
not fighting for it's so inefficient
it's so gosh that's so sad well let me
step in and and I'll and I'm I'm Richard
I'm here to help well rich people and
and wealthy corporations spent a
generation waging a war on government
defunding government allowing social
problems to fester and allowing their
own profits to soar and then with
government weakened social problems
multiplying in their own pockets full
they reinvent themselves as the new
replacement of government which is you
know instead of trickle-down economics
we now have trickle-down change let them
make their fortune and you know and then
they'll just throw some social change
down from the mountain well we have to
decide in America if that's the kind of
change we want but what I do know is if
you project that kind of change
backwards throughout time we wouldn't
have created most of the change that we
all take for granted
I mean if if you know there would
frankly have been no New Deal there'd be
no modern American economy if we had
depended on the powerful to throw down
scraps many of the most important things
in American life had to be taken from
the powerful and given to the many and
it's it's time that we reclaim that
heritage again I think it's hard to
understand why populism is rising
throughout the world without reckoning
with the role of a class of global
one-percenters who are remote from their
communities more connected to each other
than to the communities they live in
and seemingly devoted to profit and
returns above all else the fascinating
and complicated thing about this global
populist moment is that it takes very
different forms I mean here there's a
very strong racial dynamic to it that is
at the heart of it there are other
places where that's less of a factor in
some places it's about you know internal
racial things in other places about
immigration in some places it's about
all of the above but I think what is
undeniable in this country is that for
30 or 40 years many people on the left
and right have felt that things were not
going right that the country wasn't
working for them that it felt rigged to
them that it felt impossible to secure
the life that they were promised by this
country and to give their children
something better than they had and that
me all that while there was a lot of
rich splaining to those people by the
American elite that no know things are
great trades good trades gonna trick
trade trades great to be perfect it's
gonna lift everybody up globalization
perfect it's great look there's a couple
of bumps but no worries and in the
aggregate all will be well I mean as
though anybody lives in the aggregate
and tech don't don't worry don't worry
about that fact that you know everything
got automated and your jobs all went to
Taiwan don't worry about it you know it
will be better off on the whole and
there was just a lot of this kind of
rich explaining I grew up and I remember
studying these the stuff in college when
I took economics classes like III went
to the University of Michigan I was
sitting in Michigan and
he cannot econ 101 and I remember
getting this lecture on how all this
stuff was for the good and as we better
off and right around us all around us in
Michigan in 1999 the state was falling
apart these long tectonic shifts we're
basically like work was disappearing and
trade was not benefiting most people and
globalization was not a walk in the park
and aggregate effects were not really of
any comfort to anybody and how was it
possible at the University of Michigan
in 1999 with all of that evidence all
around us that we could sit in an
intellectual cocoon and explain to
ourselves that you know rising tides
lift all boats essentially there is a
way in which American elites and this is
not just a couple of greedy hedge fund
billionaires America the American
intelligentsia also has been complicit
in a false story about they're all
things working out for people over the
last generation that wasn't true and I
think people felt that and revolted
against it and it's really really
unfortunate that particularly in the
Trump movement the someone who actually
tapped into that intuition people have
that elites weren't maybe as sincere in
fighting for them as as they claimed
that Donald Trump instead of seizing on
that anger and channeling at the
institutions and people who had actually
done that instead in this cowardly and
sad and lowly and hateful way deflect to
that anger onto Muslims and immigrants
and women and people of color and
whatever you know that's the the
ultimate and tragic non-sequitur of
American politics today people are
correctly people correctly feel screwed
by an economic order that doesn't have
as much space for regular people to make
a life as it used to but they have been
led by a phony billionaire real estate
developer to feel as though those
problems were caused not by Goldman
Sachs but by black people and that is
the tragedy of this moment and that's
why it's going to take
someone on the Democratic side who is
actually able to speak to the concerns
of regular people about being shut out
by the way there's more shut out people
on the Democratic voter base than the
Republican voter base but the Democrats
I think have struggled to speak in the
language of people who feel left out by
the future
socially many of the most prominent
Democrats just they don't know and live
among those people you can you can have
a lot of heart and you can have a good
speechwriter but you either live in a
world that has more Goldman Sachs people
in it or a world that has more union
organizers in it it's it's it's just as
your real friends as your as your real
fellow travelers and I think people are
actually good at sniffing who's who and
I think the democratic party needs to
get serious about being the party of of
regular people who feel shut out by this
age and that that must mean not being
the party of Goldman Sachs in any way
[Music]